[Music]
hello and welcome to how the light gets
in festival i'm grace blakely author of
the corona crush how the pandemic will
change capitalism and stolen how to save
the world from financialization and
today i'm going to be interviewing the
brilliant rooker bregman author of uh
humankind a hopeful history i'm going to
be talking about that book humankind
today which i would really encourage
everyone to purchase and read so the
first question to you ruka
is for all the talk of solidarity and
elevating our common humanity why do you
think that so many people have such a
hard time believing that all human
beings are basically
yeah that's really the central question
isn't it um if people are really
fundamentally decent then uh yeah why do
so many of us believe that we're
basically totally selfish
and you know what i've got i've got a
very long answer to that
because i basically think there are four
reasons and i try to go through them
quickly so the first one is relatively
straightforward right it's uh
it's the news it's the kind of
information that we get every day the
news is mostly about stuff that goes
wrong about corruption and terrorism and
violence so if you watch a lot of the
news then at the end of the day you'll
be quite cynical and you get what
psychologists call the mean world
syndrome you know this this feeling that
the world is just a nasty and evil place
so perhaps it's uh it's good for your
mental health to just follow a little
bit less of the news but then obviously
i mean the news is a relatively modern
phenomenon and um
this
cynical view of human nature has been
with us for a very long time i think you
could even argue that it's one of the
central ideas in western culture this
idea that people deep down are just
selfish and that our civilization is
only a thin veneer you know only a thin
layer and below that lies raw human
nature it goes back all the way to the
ancient greeks you can find it among the
orthodox christians you know saint
augustine uh writing about the notion of
original sin that we're all sinners you
can find it among the enlightenment
philosophers among social darwinists in
the 19th century it's embedded at the
heart of capitalism again this idea that
people are just selfish and greed is
good etc etc so from the left to the
right from from people who are religious
to atheists this idea comes back again
and again and again
and um
sorry this is a way too long answer but
just one final thing to say is that the
reason
i think it comes back again and again
and again
is that it's in the interest of those in
power
because
if we cannot trust each other
then we need
those at the top
then we need hierarchy um we need kings
and queens and presidents and ceos and
you name it uh basically we need uh a
leviathan as thomas hopps the the famous
british philosopher called it someone to
keep us in check because otherwise we
start looting and plundering and killing
each other and we we
behave as the kids in lord of the flies
so it's um this cynical selfish view of
human nature is is i think the ultimate
legitimization of power differences in
hierarchy and that's why this book
humankind may come across as this uh i
don't know self-helpy book about oh the
power of kindness
but i think it's actually a quite
subversive political book
if you
really get what it's about um
you know changing our view of human
nature it has quite revolutionary
implications
yeah absolutely and i think certainly
with the kind of you know revival of
this idea of democratic socialism that
we're seeing in lots of parts of the
world that's really premised upon the
idea that we are capable of cooperating
within institutions within democratic
institutions to actually make the world
a better place so i completely agree
that this is really radical political
stuff
um you mentioned that the idea that you
know if we were all left wearing devices
it would end up like lord of the flies
right but in your book you have a really
fascinating anecdote about the real lord
of the flies it's more than an anger
actually it's an incredible story can
you just um tell us a little bit about
that story and the kind of research that
you did to find out about it sure well
many of us will probably have read lord
of the flies i uh read it when i was i
think around 16 or 17 years old and i
remember feeling quite depressed
afterwards um
like uh no more harry potter for me this
is what kids are really like that's what
i thought uh it was only years later
while i was working on this project that
i wondered
um
could lord of the flies just be you know
another version of this veneer theory
you know this this deep uh deeply
influential idea in western culture um
and has everyone
ever checked what would really happen if
kids would ship wreck on an island
now
obviously it's uh it's hard for
scientists to convince parents to send
their kids to uninhabited islands right
so it's hard to test this scientifically
what would happen but you could look at
natural experiments so i just
basically just started googling right
whether
it has ever happened um and then i
stumbled upon this obscure blog that
told a story about something that had
supposedly happened in the 60s
near tonga which is an island group in
the pacific ocean where supposedly six
kids had shipwrecked
and then i devoted uh around a year of
my life to this story
because uh i managed to track down the
original lord of the flies children um
six stunwin boys
who are now around 17 years old four of
them are still alive um they're around
70 years old now and
they did shipwreck on an island and they
behaved in a very very different way uh
from from the lord of the flies children
it's a it's a quite hopeful story if it
would be a hollywood film then people
would say oh this is highly unrealistic
you know kids would never cooperate like
that but you know it really happened
personally i think that it should be a
hollywood film maybe that's one for your
next project
well it is it is going to be so they've
great yeah yeah so we've we formed a
team you know the fourth survivor
and and the captain who found them who
sadly passed away a couple of weeks ago
his name is peter warner um so yeah we
together we sold the rights to a new
regency they've also
done 12 years a slave and bohemian
rhapsody so now it's going to be this
huge
production uh it's been a it's been
absolutely yeah it's been a crazy
experiment experience but you know it's
just one wonderful story and i think
that if if kids from around the globe
still have to read lord of the flies in
school today which is which is fine i
think it's an interesting novel and it
you know ask some important questions um
but then please let's also tell them
about this one time that we know of in
all of world history where real kids
shipwrecked on a real island because
that's a completely totally different
story of of kids who cooperated for 15
months
and um who who stayed the best of
friends basically one of my favorite
parts of the book and um the you know
the title of the episode of when i had
you on my podcast that i used was this
idea of survival of the friendliest um i
particularly really found those studies
that demonstrated that the thing that
really differentiates human beings from
other animals isn't necessarily
massive you know levels of intelligence
but actually sociality can you explain
this idea of survival of the friendliest
and why it's so important for kind of
explaining why human beings have this
natural capacity to kind of work
together to solve their collective
problems for a long time evolutionary
psychology told this quite
cynical story about selfish genes
and that perhaps we just need to teach
our kids generosity and altruism because
they are born selfish if you studied
biology in the 1970s that was basically
uh the story that your teachers would
tell you
um but there's really been a scientific
revolution or a sort of silent
scientific revolution in the last couple
of decades so many experts from very
different disciplines have moved on to a
more hopeful view of human nature and so
biologists have indeed come to talk
about this whole concept of survival of
the friendliest which basically means
that for millennia it was not the
nastiest among us or the smartest among
us but actually the friendliest who had
the most kids and still had the biggest
chance of passing on their genes to the
next generation
now the question is obviously how do we
know this
um
there's a there's a there's a name for
this uh theory they call it
self-domestication
um i guess we we all know what
domesticated animals are we've got cows
we've got pigs and and sheep etc
and we know that for a long time we've
selected these animals for tameness and
friendliness and
biologists have known for a very long
time that if you domesticate an animal
you start seeing this list of of traits
so domesticated animals have thinner
bones uh smaller brains they're much
more playful it's as if they never
really want to grow up um
and this whole list of traits together
it's called domestication syndrome and
what's really interesting about human
beings if that is that if you look at
this list you start to think but wait a
minute humans are quite domesticated
right we are very slow to grow up you
know some people never grow up we are
very playful especially when when we're
young we have smaller brains compared to
our ancestors if you compare homo
sapiens skeletons from 50 40 30 20 000
years ago um you see that difference um
so in many ways it seems to be the case
that we are domesticated but then the
question is who did it you know who
tamed us who has domesticated us and the
answer that scientists now give is
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas
you